you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 25
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I'd like to share with you
another group of basic checkmate
patterns if you've been tracking this
playlist you'll know the previous video
covered five checkmate patterns I have
nine to share with you and this one 24
total examples many of them very quick
covering the double Bishop mate bottoms
mate valestra arabian corner more fees
Pillsbury's damiano's lollies don't be
too fixated on the names i said this in
the last video knowing the names is not
nearly as important as knowing what that
looks like on board we want to become
familiar with how the pieces interact I
must admit that for me some of the names
well that was news to me or in other
words I knew what it looked like on
board and only later did I realize oh it
has a name and oh that's what it's
called okay great so I knew what it
looked like before knowing that it
actually had a name anyhow these
examples that I'm going to share with
you I'm pulling from Ali chess org
forward slash practice I've included a
link in the description if you would
like to maybe try these on your own
first with that said I think we could
just go ahead and dive right in
throughout this video I'll be adding
some tips if I think it'll be beneficial
to you highlighting squares drawing
arrows anything that I think will help
you to better recognize these patterns
when you sit down at the board
so with that said let's have a look at
example one covering the double bishop
mate three examples highlighting the
double bishop mate white and moving this
one and it's a Czech million one
Bishop to d4 and that's mate what more
can I add all the squares are going to
be taken away from the enemy King there
is something I could add here bishops
that function on adjacent diagonals you
might want to have that register in your
mind is having some added value there's
some nice synergy when bishops function
on diagonals that are right next to each
other especially when both bishops are
pointing at the enemy King Bishop d4
will do the trick and this one white to
move here it's another checkmate and one
and the bishop takes bishop here and all
the squares will be taken away from the
black King and one last example
highlighting the double Bishop mate
black to move here this is a checkmate
in two
Bishop covers these two and yeah after
this move here Queen takes pawn sack
sacrificing the Queen giving up the
Queen Bishop takes Bishop is mate added
value when those bishops are functioning
on adjacent diagonals moving on now to
bottoms mates this once more involves
the two bishops only this time
interacting in a crisscross way notice
the dark square Bishop is already taking
away a couple important squares from the
enemy King knifing in there if only we
can cover these two squares and we can
it's going to be mate with Bishop to a64
Botton's mates Bishop's functioning in a
criss cross way towards the enemy King
something a bit more practical
middlegame type position black to move
one Bishop is knifing in if we could
somehow get the bishop safely to a 3
that would be mate the pawn is covering
a 3 however the pawn on b2 is covering a
3 in fact here's a term I get to cover
the b2 pun we can say is overloaded he
has one job too many
two jobs in this case defense III and a
three
Queen takes c3 that forces pawn takes
that was wits check and now we could
sweep in for Botton's mate one last
example for Botton's mate just kind of
flipped here playing on whites and this
Bishop knifes in we could only get here
safely and we can in this case it's the
b7 pond that is overloaded clean
sweeping into c6 capturing the pond with
Czech forces pawn takes Queen and
finally we deliver Botton's mate that
little crisscross pattern towards the
enemy king
okay only one example now highlighting
what's known as the Balestra mate and
this is one of them that was news to me
when I was you know in the intro to this
video yeah this was this was one of the
names yeah that was nice to me I didn't
know the name of this one that was
familiar with the pattern the Queen and
Bishop working together in other words
Bishop to d6 is going to be checkmate
what more can I offer with this one well
here's something that I think might be
useful to you when that enemy King is on
the edge and your queen is positioned a
knight's move away from that king take
note of what color square that queen is
on okay if she's on a light square she
covers all light squares that the King
could potentially run away to it's only
the dark squares that are going to be
safe for the King so with that said
guess what peace would complement a
queen that is on a light square dark
square bishop
course the other way to look at it Queen
on a dark square light square bishop
will compliment that Queen very well in
this case Bishop to d6 will do the trick
a bit of a crisscross type pattern a bit
of a Botton's like mate in a way there
is some additional squares that the
Queen is of course taking away from the
enemy King Bishop d6 does the trick
olestra me moving on to
Arabian mate this involves the rook in
the night a night one position two
squares from the corner is very powerful
so much so that a rook combined with
that Knight on either g8 or h7 and both
are going to be mate if we could somehow
get the rook here or here it's going to
be mate of course the rook doesn't move
like this in this case rook h7 is mate
example of Arabian mate a little bit
more involved we can first like to move
here we can first make use of this pawn
being in a pin it is not able to capture
be in check we can go to f6 we could go
to that post that is two squares away
from the corner square and now if only
we can pull off a rook g8 move or rook
h7 move that's the final thing that we
really want to crash through with well
we can do that rook takes pawn pawn
takes rook and there we go
click on g8 game over and on rip takes
pawn Knight block we would simply take
the knight let's see what black does rip
takes pawn okay computer went with a
knight block and we simply take the
knight for mates the arabian mate one
last example highlighting the arabian
mate in this particular case the knight
isn't going to function two squares away
from the corner square we can capture on
f7 here eliminating an important
defender of g6
we now make use of that square forcing
and only move King g8
rook sweeps in for checkmate moving on
to the highly creative corner mate who
came up with that one anyhow enemy king
is in the corner he's restricted greatly
as soon as the knight makes a move the
rook will cover these two and we need
only we only have to cover the corner
square Knight f7 will do the trick
nothing fancy going on here and one last
example for corner mate playing as black
here we're really close to giving mate
these two squares taken away by the
black rook Knight f2 will give check but
the rook is covering that well let's get
rid of the defender of f2 we can first
sacrifice the Queen in LA then deliver
this corner mate okay moving on to more
fees mate there are four examples
covering more fees mate this highlights
an interaction between rook and Bishop
and it's the bishop that usually
delivers that final blow he's the one
that's delivering
checkmate in this case a bit of a corner
mate for this particular example
Bishop to f6 and these two are covered
Bishop to f6 will take away that corner
square for me second of four examples
this is a checkmate to roof g4 first and
then Bishop delivering me example three
or four rook g1 check
computer move just delaying mate for as
long as possible and now we can crash
through here Rick takes night King takes
and then we take here and then go here
next for checkmate okay in this case
they can wait in the corner
we could take here and this will lead to
Czech maple we could do things in a much
more forceful way
rook to g8 gives Czech there's two ways
to capture the rook rook takes rook we
would then play Queen takes f6 the rook
would have to block and then we would
take the rook for me and the other
variation would be after rook g8 King
takes rook this allows the Queen to
sweep over to function just like a rook
the King would then have to go into the
corner and then Bishop takes f6 would be
mate let's see what option black chooses
rook takes rook so now we sweep in on f6
and then capture here so not really a
more fees like mate but in that other
variation it would have turned out to be
like a more fees mate one last example
highlighting more fees mate rook and
Bishop converging on g7 this
intersection squared g7 that's a check
and if we move the rook well wherever we
move the rook next it's going to be
check if we backup that will allow black
to block with f6 so we should first we
should first take out that pun we can
now return to g7 it's a bit of a
windmill tactic something I covered
several videos ago in this playlist
now that the pond isn't done f7 anymore
we can drop back to I believe any of
these squares and it will be leading to
checkmate so let's just go here black
could only make a couple blocks we take
with the bishop and take once more with
the bishop for more fees mates three
more to cover pills berries mate is next
once again involving a rook and Bishop
the only difference is that it's the
rook who's really delivering the final
blow these two squares are cut out by
the bishop and we just have to deliver a
file check for mate in this case and one
last example for pills berries mate we
can go with a queen sacrifice everything
is pointing at g7 here something has to
happen
Queen takes g7 rook takes g7 check and
now what do we do we can let's see rook
to g8
we'll be a double-check that's the most
forceful check in the game forces a king
move so rook to g8 forces King takes
rook and then we would sweep over with
the other rook the Queen will have to
block and then we capture the Queen for
me rook g8 is it rook G 1 and now rook
takes Queen it's the rook is delivering
the mate the rook and Bishop working
well together
Damiano is mate
with this one this involves a pawn or a
bishop in close proximity to the enemy
King and the most powerful piece around
namely the Queen we can see that upon
with this kind of depth on this deep
into enemy territory especially when
close to the enemy King yeah
supports some nice squares Queen to h7
that is mate example 203 for down the UH
knows me if we could somehow get our
queen to g7 that's going to be make the
knight is in the way but we can force
him to move rook to h8 forces Knight
takes rook and now we sweep in right
next to the King for Domino's mate and
one last example this is a cool one team
black a lot of clearance sacrifices here
what we would really like to have happen
is Queen getting the Queen to h2 how can
we pull this off well we sacrifice the
rip
give a check sacrifice another rook and
now our cling is to sweep over here to H
a and finally get to H 2 for mates last
check mate pattern to cover and that is
lollies mate and how to describe this
well it involves having a pond
well yeah upon I think maybe in some
cases it could even have a a bishop
controlling this is the key point
controlling that fee and keto square
right when the bishop develops going to
g7 we consider that corner square makes
to be one square away from the corner
square this square right here
controlling that with a pond getting the
Queen involved that's going to be mate
on g7 in this case on and queen working
very well together similar case here
white to move this is a check
and now we go here notice the town is
now controlling that g7 square Queen now
sneaks in and there's nothing that black
can do to stop Queen g7 mate next one
final example our 24th example went
through these pretty quick white to move
this is going to take a little bit more
work but a nice finish here first we
activate the rook and prepare for final
flurry of moves final move sequence
bunch of sacrifices going on we capture
on h7
capture the clean wits check and before
I put it on the board after ripp takes
Queen King takes rook we would go to h6
we have the support of the bishop and
then sneak in for mate on g7 black moves
to g8 in this case this allows rip to h8
something we've already seen with
Damiano is made a bit of a clearance
tactic giving a check now we get to go
to h6 for a check and now g7 for mates
so there is some added value of course
to having a pawn so deep in enemy
territory allows us to pull off down
beyond owes mate or lolis mate in many
cases so those are the only nine that I
wanted to cover in this video feel free
to leave any feedback to this video and
I will catch you soon enough in a video
26 that's all for now hope having a
great day and I will catch you soon take
care bye
you